okay guess I don't do well in these kind
of situations so now we're sitting at
the people are gonna see this scene in
the movie let's just say I'll never look
at fortune you don't don't eat biscuit
dough this is terrifying do you want
side trouble getting through this movie
like this was really really terrifying
to watch
is there a scary movie for you that
really freaked you guys out Exorcist yes
I saw like when I was like eight that
was scary
I was always freaked out by Freddy
Krueger yes I was a big one oh yeah have
a Johnny Depp lines yes but you both
have young daughters now how long would
you wait to show them this movie we did
13 no I think oh no it's rated R yeah
there's no work so I think we should
wait til they are 17 years old okay yeah
yeah okay every time in my daughter he
is just the music in the background if
I'm looking at something she has the
music the theme tune of this movie she's
like so already it's telling to work its
magic yeah now just guys saw the
Instagram that you post a few be a CEO
of the post-production how was that
experience
no it was a bit fun and silly and I was
actually I'll tell you this I I've lost
my voice on many of films with Andy
misskaddy because the ADR of screaming
and like and all those noises that you
have to make really wore me out yeah
this movie in particular that the ADR
post record session was a marathon yeah
it was like five hours of running on the
spot I'm sweating screaming I mean when
I saw your Instagram post of the cut
together what I mean you're both
involved in that scene what how many
like it was a third of the movie you're
covered in blood yeah I didn't
understand that when I agreed to it I
didn't understand he told me about the
scene I was like that's great at first
he said the blood is gonna stop here and
then I was like well I feels like we
took him out a bit like I feel like
we're doing it she's stuff
she's gonna drown show it to this but
there I didn't realize that I was gonna
be wearing the blood for over a month
they would be pouring it on me after you
know it died my hair did yeah because
I'd like the color from it I'm gonna
have like like dark red spots in my hair
yeah we wouldn't have to wait and
they're cold rolling camera and then you
have to wait for Jessica's floating to
sit and then we were like okay we're all
right she's ready so this is the final
chapter I know but this movie is
probably going to be a massive hit
were there any way you'd be interested
in Chapter three if they come up with
some kind of story no no this is it
can't and I don't listen up I would say
no because and II would never make a
chapter three yeah and we've run out of
a book he's done now you know the two
pots so it would have to be made up this
is Hollywood Oh vision no but they'd
have to get a new Beverly I think maybe
know that well another 27 ears and
Stephen King would have to start writing
now yeah well congratulations Ruby it
was enjoyable
I'll get wrong it freaked me out people
are gonna love this movie fans gonna
love it so congratulations thank you
enjoy your food